let's jump to this story from the Daily
Mail
oregonians Force vote to secede from the
woke State and become part of Idaho two
counties are set to vote on the measure
after nine backed it due to defund the
police critical race theory in schools
and bail laws before we get to the point
where states secede from the union
before we get to the point where anyone
is trying to engage in a civil war the
first that's happening is in Oregon
they're not trying to leave the union
they're trying to move a portion of the
state into a different state I don't
know if they have a picture of the of
the whole there you go look at this
greater Idaho hey I'm all for it man I
think it's exactly what needs to happen
so uh Portland can they can they can
have their weird urban center in fact
this is what should happen across the
board every major city you can just be
your own every major city becomes its
own uh city-state State yeah back to
city and what happens is the Democrats
end up with like 12 senators and
Republicans end up with you know 60.
right and so that's sort of the thing is
you have so many states where there are
these large Urban centers that control
everything and have and have the biggest
population that are left-wing and then
all of the rest of the state which
encompasses a much bigger land mass but
has fewer people rural much more
conservative and they get out voted in a
lot of kids I mean even a state like
Maryland which is pretty democratic
you don't have Baltimore you don't have
Prince George's County Montgomery County
where all the government employees live
it's Maga country it's it's my good
country yeah right now we're in Maryland
and it's Maga country New York these
Three Counties issued a letter saying
they wanted to secede and join West
Virginia
hmm yeah wow there you go
the problem is this stuff isn't
happening and it needs to happen the the
shift the votes should be very easy it
prevents in destabilization it prevents
Civil War if greater Idaho happened
there would be people would feel
satiated they'd feel satisfied they'd
feel like their voices were heard and
this makes sense for them and they
wouldn't be part of a state that was
abusive towards them instead what's
happening is greater Idaho you have
these nine counties and they're saying
like hey we shouldn't be here and
they're like shut your mouths well what
do you think that leads to secession
usually yeah eventually they're gonna be
back then we're out we're just grumbling
and conflict grumbling acceptance but I
mean what would this do this would if
this did happen it would cut back on the
amount of votes that Oregon would no uh
well yeah Oregon would lose votes Idaho
would gain votes in Congress but
Senators would stay the same so they're
not even trying to make their own state
they're trying to just become part of a
different one there's a similar thing
happening in Northern Colorado Northern
California the state of Jefferson
Northern California and that that should
happen I think so new States hey you
know we don't need 50 states forever I
know it's a nice round number but let's
just split up make them smaller I think
that might be kind of neat there will
always be a certain number of people
though who will they live in Portland
and they'll see this new expanded Idaho
and they'll say oh that looks really
nice I want to live there and then they
go live there and they say I actually
want to vote though for all the policies
I had in Portland then they don't make
any association between the policies and
why Portland was bad and Idaho is good
look there's a video from Ami Horowitz
and prageru
and he walks up to people and he's
asking them to I think sign a petition
uh to allow a five-year-old to undergo a
sex change operation
and in one of the conversations this
woman goes I completely agree with this
and then he's like yeah you know
five-year-old kids can make their own
decisions they know what's right for
their body because I agree thank you so
much for doing this and it's like
conservatives think this is a gotcha
like they're exposing it these people
genuinely believe this stuff there's
you're not like waking them up to make
them realize they're wrong they're
saying like no I agree I I believe this
and you're like aha I've exposed you and
they're like no I talk about this all
the time we we have child drag shows we
do this all the time you're not you're
you what happens is conservatives
can't believe that the average person
would support this and then when they
talk to these people and hear them
saying they support they're like look
look everybody this person supports it
and then all of the the body snatcher
people turn slowly and look at you and
go because they all agree with it
they're all on board with it there there
is a there's an ideological fracture in
this country I ain't being mended
so maybe
maybe greater Idaho needs to happen huh
yeah I think it does I think Western uh
Maryland needs to break off and become
part of West Virginia
it definitely makes more sense but I I
think a lot of bureaucrats want their
tax cattle to stay because they want to
treat them like cattle and they want to
of course siphon off all the money and
wealth that they can from them to
finance their Insanity because if the
people leave who's going to finance a
lot of this Insanity as of course a lot
of the people are in the rural areas uh
usually are independent usually are
people working for themselves usually
are people who are successful and
um yeah you know they want that money so
I don't see this happening yeah or
Oregon's not going to let you tax cattle
you call them yeah slaves yeah pretty
much
you get nothing you can't do anything
about it and we get money from you why
would you why would we let you leave
what do we gain from it yeah and we get
to impose any kind of policies we want
on you so what's the incentive of
Portland letting them go is there is
there any incentive uh Portland would
get their their voting ideology more
prominent in State Legislature
just I just want everybody in in Eastern
Idaho to realize
your life is being dictated to by a
bunch of 20 year old lunatics who've not
had jobs running around Portland
smashing things and starting fires
so when you're say working on a farm
working hard every day to provide for
your family to produce food and crops
that human beings need
your life is controlled by a crackpot 20
year old white leftist who weighs 110
pounds soaking wet running around going
America is racist and then screaming
racial slurs at black cops because
they're apparently the The Virtuous ones
and then setting fires and fire bombing
buildings and law enforcement won't
arrest them and then they go and vote
and the politics pen to them and they
are in charge of you congratulations
so I don't blame him for wanting to vote
to leave the problem is the system
doesn't allow it like it's become too
rigid like you were saying earlier when
it comes to the Constitution all of
these things like the age you have to be
we were very serious about this but the
actual enumerated powers that's
how what do we do what do we do do we
just sit back and wait until the whole
thing explodes we're not supposed to
we're supposed to change it as we go
that's very very intentional Convention
of States new Amendment a path towards
shifting borders of states very easily
it should be extremely easy for this to
happen not ridiculously hard granted
I don't understand why Oregon as a state
should have a voting right over a county
that votes to leave why would that be
well I didn't have no disruption to
taxes yeah it would be too bad like
imagine if if you know you know uh you
you have a roommate and then I say well
look it's my house and I've determined
you're not allowed to leave you got to
keep paying rent you'd be like not later
you walk out the door right it's gone
for imagine if the police said well hold
on the guy who owns the house has said
you're not allowed to do that so we're
under arrest and we're bringing you back
that's insane it makes no sense it would
be more like if I'm like no this room
that I'm renting from you is my house
now or I'd be like no this room I'm
renting in your house belongs to your
neighbor you'd be like no it's my room
well I suppose it's a little different
because we're talking about a space
that's very far away and not occupied by
a person so how about a garage
let's say that uh you own the garage
and uh
it's I I don't I don't know how that
would actually work because if people
own the land they're on you know what I
mean it can be like a good point yeah
but the landowners should be able to
decide what state they're a part of
right they should and then they all vote
as their County and if the County votes
why should Oregon why should Portland be
able to be like nah you can't leave and
what would their mechanism really be at
that point now obviously we can think of
some pretty horrible things that would
be their mechanism but I don't think
that would be
the first thing out of the gate that
would happen so there'd be lawsuits but
they have no police they can't enforce
any laws
Eastern Idaho if they vote for this and
then decide it is it is period
Portland can that the Oregon government
can be like we do not recognize the
secession of Eastern Oregon and they can
be like what are you going to do about
it what are you gonna do you're gonna go
to every single County and every single
family and then occupy their
neighborhoods at gunpoint never going to
happen if the confidence of the people
of Greater Idaho of the people of
Eastern Oregon is that we do not
recognize the state of Oregon anymore
there is literally nothing anyone can do
to stop them it would be like a civil
disobedient act they would say we're not
paying taxes to the state of uh Oregon
anymore we're paying them to the state
of Idaho and then Oregon would be like
no pay us your taxes they're like well
we're idahoan now and then the Idaho
would send out the National Guard if
they if it escalated the Idaho it's put
the National Guard in the new territory
if Idaho accepted it yeah yeah and then
say this is our state but what I'm
saying is let's say Idaho says look we
don't want to get involved in this
or again as a state then says these
regions aren't allowed to secede but you
can look on the map where you can see
all of the areas that have voted in
favor of joining Idaho I mean it's it's
there it's like almost the entirety of
Eastern Oregon if they all if all the
people there simply said my government
is you know this person if if these
people these counties all have their
County Commissioners or whatever and
they say
the laws that I follow come from the
County Commission are not from a state
we don't recognize Oregon can do nothing
the feds can do nothing the feds cannot
go people need to understand this there
are not enough federal agents to
actually go into an entire State and
enforce the law they would have to
occupy every city Corner they would have
to go door to door they would have to
arrest everyone it will never happen
that's only if the majority of these
people stop abiding by state government
and decide they're their own State the
feds have no choice but to recognize it
otherwise there's just nothing that you
can't do anything about it it's that's
just it
you were saying something before and I
cut you off I'm sorry about that I would
just tend to think that the in Oregon or
any place like that the tax enforcement
authorities would be the last police
that would be defunded those would be
fully funded so Civil Disobedience acts
by not paying taxes I think they do have
a response to uh but what I mean is if
every single person there just stopped
abiding they couldn't do anything about
it I mean by all means go ahead and
arrest every single citizen of this
County it's just not going to happen
it's a form of implosion it would just
destroy well there's not enough Law
Enforcement Officers look in New York
City I think there's what like 40 000
cops is that is that the number Luke I
think 30 000. yeah tens of thousands
tens of thousands out of out of a city
with with uh with what nine million in
its City in City borders nine million
people if nine million people in New
York just stopped paying their taxes
what are the cops gonna do about it so
is that not something I'm advocating for
I'm saying if that were to occur that
the government can't do anything it's
the government exists through the
confidence of the people the people
believe the government has the authority
or is Justified then they follow along
but if these people are voting to say
we're no longer part of Oregon we're
getting to that point where they're
going to say Oregon you do not represent
us like imagine if you know California
tried passing this bill I don't know if
they did where they can tax someone 10
years after they leave the state did you
guys hear about this one yes imagine
you're living in Texas and California
knocks on your door and says yours taxes
you'd be like get out I don't live in
California go away what gives you the
right that's how people here are going
to feel
so New York City has 36 000 police
officers and 19 000 civilian employees
so right that's you know 36 000 officers
think about how small that number is oh
it sounds big 36 000. how many people
are in the New York Metro you want to
look it up is it 12 million I think it's
like 9.5 or something I thought it was
18 is it nine well in in the in the
Metro you've got other police outside of
that so let's just say City proper in
the in the in the in the city proper
jurisdiction what's the population 20
million in the city yeah no New York
metropolitan area population the Metro
includes like Jersey City and and things
outside of New York yeah yeah yeah so
City population proper I think is like
nine or something
NYC let's look up the uh the official
City box 8.4 million eight point as of
2013 it was 8.4 8.8 as of 2020. I got it
here from Wikipedia April 1st 8.8
million that's wow that went down
yeah man crazy I'm pretty sure it was
higher than that before but whatever
yeah it's it's in Decline
so 8.8 million people
if let's say uh one percent of the
population of New York just uh let's say
they got infected they got zombie virus
that right on the running round the 88
000 people there's not nearly enough
police officers to deal with that one
percent if one percent now let's go back
in time and let's let's go back to a
time when New York had 100 people living
in it
if one percent went nuts no problem one
guy one guy running around they just
they just tie them up
then you get to the point where there's
a million and one percent now you've got
thousands and that's getting much much
more difficult to deal with with 8.8
million people
one percent of the population outright
just going out and saying you know hey
we're gonna Riot the police can do
literally nothing and that's why in 2020
the police could do literally nothing
too many people write it overwhelm the
police force doesn't work so what do you
do I'm open to new ideas you know the
United States is um an experiment it's
one of the most experimental governments
maybe to ever have been tried well I
don't know if that's I can't claim that
but it's it's government is experimental
and to think that we could split up
States and move them around and move
around counties that's fascinating and
it could be fantastic for for
communication and for the peaceful you
know settlement
let's let's let's talk about the New
York Metro 20 million the New York Metro
is 20 million so this includes uh just
north of what is it like Westchester and
like Jersey City and Union City in Long
Island a little bit dirty Jersey I think
dirty Jersey and all that stuff Bayonne
or whatever
20 million people
if one percent
wow
if one percent of that
are we are we looking at is that that's
that's uh 200 000 people
if if one percent of the New York Metro
went into Manhattan in a rage 200 000
people running through the streets
smashing and riding the police would be
on the first boat helicopter or car out
of the city and say I ain't dealing with
this you saw it possible did you see
what happened during the black lives
matter protests a lot of them were like
oh yeah we're just gonna I'm not gonna
do anything we're just gonna sit back
and stand back that's that's what I've
talked about the the the more massive
the population you need a massive number
of law enforcement to deal with it
imagine if one percent of New York
citizens were just like we are no longer
complying with government the police
would be unable to do anything about it
and that's literally what's happening
mind you the reason crime is
skyrocketing did you guys see this uh
brawl Mart video they're calling it yes
people in Walmart they're just fighting
like crazy yeah the reason why people
tended not to fight is like I don't want
to get arrested like you know I I get it
now no one is getting arrested they know
they're not getting arrested so they're
like what do I care
now you've got a dude Buck Naked running
around the Subways of New York New York
Subway City uh New York City subway
killings are our 25-year High yeah
people being pushed onto the tracks
young women being murdered because they
know they're not getting arrested they
do the police cannot deal with it so
it's a Cascade effect
when 36 000 cops
can deal with the crime and people
believe the police can deal with the
crime crimes is lower because people are
worried criminals are like you got to be
careful the cops will get you now that
confidence is being shattered it's going
to create a snowball rolling down a hill
effect where more and more criminals are
like cops aren't going to do anything
yeah this is why according to some
estimates ridership in the New York City
uh subway system is down significantly
because a lot of people are afraid to go
on the New York City subway system it's
also one of the main reasons why people
are fleeing New York City and escaping a
lot of these failed policies that were
implemented and of course bought for by
George Soros that of course planted a
whole bunch of District Attorneys and
woke individuals into governments that
of course are pushing policies that are
absolutely nonsensical obviously there's
a legitimate conversation to have about
Criminal Justice Reform yes but when you
have that same Criminal Justice Reform
being turned to punish people for
political thoughts and ideas when you
have the the Manhattan district attorney
focusing on Donald Trump as violence is
engulfing that entire city there there
should be someone saying hey you should
get your priorities straight hey we
shouldn't be letting criminals off into
the streets that are extremely violent
that are going to be hurting people
maybe we should stop focusing on
punishing people for their political
ideas and maybe we should actually start
serving and protecting the the
population of the country this is really
cool check this out this is the uh a map
of the New York metropolitan area
so you can see that you've got you know
like New York down here but it goes up
to Putnam it goes up to Pike County
Sussex more so it's massive stuff like
all of Long Island is basically included
in it
this is
it's massive just put it simply and I I
don't know we know there's 36 000 police
in New York City proper for eight
million people I wonder what the total
police population of the entire New York
Metro would be I would imagine it's not
relative uh it it doesn't scale the
amount of police you need in like
Somerset is substantially less per per
person per capita than you would need in
a very dense New York city so my view is
going to be it's 50 000 for the entire
metro Maybe
yeah but but you know at least we're
gonna have 87 000 IRS agents according
to the inflation reduction act that was
of course promptly promoted by Bill
Gates who's openly bragging how he was
the one that came forward with this bill
so who cares about real law enforcement
you could have IRS agents walking around
armed with guns they just got to do the
robot stealing your money the dog drones
you know what I mean so so when you act
a fool the Drone flies to your house and
then dispatches the little dog guy with
the gun on his back in it
citizen you have violated the law and
then you're like ah crap
ever punched a dog
um no yeah me neither I think that
you're right a metal one that it's it
doesn't scale like plus the streets are
too small so like even if you had 10
times the cops they couldn't even fit to
stop the crowd so this is why they're
going into anti-terrorism laws they want
Strategic Defense against this kind of
stuff they look for like ring leaders
they want to take it out at the source
so that big crowds don't proliferate and
drones I'm very concerned about the use
of mechanical drones in oh yeah police
defense like they're doing in China they
literally quadcoptered in a Boston
Dynamic it wasn't a Boston Dynamic robot
but it was a similar model like that the
dog with a with a gun on its back and
the Drone drops it yeah it like that's
one way really small drone police force
it's terrifying though because it can be
co-opted and hacked and stuff Terminator
scenario could very well happen and I
know like in the movie it's this it's
his fanciful AI that like I guess Skynet
declares war on Humanity or whatever
robots fight humans it could be
something as simple as we program robots
for law enforcement
we give them specific parameters but
humans are imperfect and the programming
is imperfect and then all of a sudden
all of the robo dogs think they're
enforcing the law perfectly and they're
just targeting anyone it could be as
simple as this right I'll give you an
example I talk about this doc the Doctor
Who episode where they go to this planet
everyone's dead and there are robots
that have these screens with smiley
faces and what they discover is that the
robots were programmed to keep people
happy
when some when an old woman died a
member of The Colony everybody got sad
the robots tried as hard as they could
to make people happy but it wasn't
working
then they found that if a sad person
came into contact with a happy person
the happy person became sad why sad
person told him old person died the
robots then started to view sadness as a
contagion and decided for the sake of
happiness it had to kill anyone who was
spreading negativity like a virus of
course that made everybody freak out and
very very unhappy to the point where
they just killed everyone that's a good
example of what happens we'll make these
robots and be like assist law
enforcement the robot drone will be like
detainment protocol suspicious activity
it'll approach a person and they'll be
like yo get that dog away from me then
it'll be like suspect is fleeing suspect
is fleeing deploy countermeasures this
causes the person to get tased trip fall
hit his head and die a bunch of people
in the area then go that thing just
killed that person for no reason they'll
start screaming and now they now the
robot robot goes assisting a criminal
assisting criminal all of these people
are now targets and then all of a sudden
the robo dogs are attacking every random
person and the AI runs amok we think
we're beyond that but these things can
happen because humans who program this
these machines are fallible and of
course the programming will be as well
and then before you know it you'll have
that other Black Mirror episode where
the robo dogs are going around hunting
people and what was it like Amazon was
delivering things that they didn't want
to them the AI was just giving them
things
man that was a crazy episode I don't
remember that part of it there were robo
dogs like patrolling and there was a
factory that just mass produced goods
for humans and there was like a
resistance and then and then it turns
out that the humans were already extinct
and that the people who you thought were
humans were actually robots created by
the AI oh my gosh because the AI needed
humans to fulfill its purpose of
delivering Goods oh goodness so crazy
yeah the the robots will be networked
and I think it's important to not start
calling them dogs keep always remember
these things are robots they're not
animals
um and so keep that in mind don't get
tricked into speaking their language and
they're going on networks and networks
can be hacked and viruses can cause
things to malfunction but but you know
look Ian like you gotta admit
everybody's got like the part of you
knows how exciting it would be to like
live in a post
post-apocalyptic world where you have
like a baseball bat on your back and
you're foraging for food and then the
robot comes and then you get into this
epic video game like battle fighting
with the robot
at least that's what people probably
assume until they actually get into a
life or death situation adrenaline kicks
in and they're begging for begging for
safety and say a savior to come you know
it's funny when people think uh there's
a there's an old joke my friend posted a
long time ago he said I want and
encourage a zombie apocalypse and it's
like people actually have fantasies
about being in the scenario and then
it's just like man anyone who's ever
been in a real life or death situation
is going to tell you that you really
really don't want anything like that no
way nope have you been close to stuff
like that Serge a few times in my life
yeah unfortunately just being in South
Africa it's kind of uh the nature of it
and also living in La for the last three
years just kind of puts you up against
whether you like it or not what'd you
notice in La did you uh the change in
the city the last three years
uh I'd say if you're everyone living in
LA right now can definitely say that
after the pandemic after 2020 things
definitely got a lot worse uh you kind
of have to remember La before you know
the pandemic started or I guess it's
just a lockdown started the before times
yeah the before times I've literally
said that before
um but it kind of just hit the fan more
so than it already was hitting the fan
and it seems like to me it's almost
unrecoverable at this point I don't want
to say that it is but it definitely
seems that way well I agree it's a
snowball rolling down a hill what was
crazier South Africa or L.A
that is a great question I kind of
realized when I was hearing about
carjackings uh home invasions uh people
just being mugged on the street for
their money and their jewelry and Etc
that I was like all right my parents
brought me to this country to take me
away from that it's time for me to like
you know make my next moves thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there